dopo merito
ecco se io mi chiedessi di
proiettato le mie spalle probabilmente
quasi tutti mi direste che questo
simbolo richiama l'infinito è come un
infinito con un piccolo spazio che viene
che descrive un percorso no allora
torniamo indietro
io torno indietro adesso mentalmente
quando ero bambino e mi immagino quante
volte ho dovuto ripetere questo gesto
per imparare come si tira l'arco perché
in realtà
voi vedete questo arco questa è una
bacchetta di legno leggermente ricurva
in questo senso possiamo rappresentarla
come schematizzando come una linea
quindi in questo modo ma per esigenze
sonore ci insegnano a dipingere
l'infinito proprio perché in questo modo
viene dato un senso di andata e ritorno
che mantiene una costanza sonora molto
differente rispetto che immaginare
questo gesto
ora da questo gesto
immaginate di accompagnare il tutto
tutto il percorso partiamo da questo
gesto ci mettiamo anche questi gesti ci
mettiamo anche lezioni di solfeggio
elezioni di coro lezioni di musica
accanto tantissime cose si può dire che
ci mettiamo una fatica infinita per
raggiungere l'infinito o perlomeno
provarci
questo si chiama tecnica
fondamentalmente è molto importante la
tecnica per un musicista e vorrei
sottolinearlo tanto perché in questo
periodo soprattutto c'è molta la
tendenza a pensare che l'artista sia
un'arte sia piombato dal nulla
uno che nasce così e che basti il
talento per essere capaci di fare
qualsiasi cosa non è niente di più
sbagliato perché prendiamo per esempio
diversi metodi ok esistono tanti metodi
esiste una scuola di violino una scuola
di musica che viene addirittura dalla
preistoria viene tramandata di
generazione in generazione
in tutto il mondo per esempio dicevo in
irlanda tutti conoscerete o perlomeno
avrete sentito il suono del fid del
violino irlandese che ha un suono
inconfondibile
pieno di quello che è la popolazione
irlandese quella allegria e insieme
malinconia che caratterizza proprio
questo suono la scuola irlandese parte
da una da un concetto che la musica
viene imparata per trasmissione non c'è
un metodo particolare un libro
immaginate in irlando in nuova scozia
che è un paese a est del canada dove il
concetto è lo stesso cioè se ci si trova
tra persone magari il più esperto
insegna al più piccolo al bambino in
questo caso o anche all'adulto che vuole
imparare e insegna come si fa però come
lo insegna dice sì suona così e se uno
ha la capacità l'intuito di capire
allora ripete quindi è un insegnamento a
specchio si potrebbe dire invece andando
a pescare da un'altra nazione la russia
per esempio in russia oltre al concetto
di imitazione c'è anche un altro
concetto che è che è il metodo rigoroso
cioè in russia si è puntato a creare
tante eccellenze misticamente parlando
perciò cosa succede che si prendono i
bambini e gli si dice prova a imitare
questo se si vede che loro riescono a
imitare con grande facilità
allora significa che loro hanno talento
musicale che è la materia prima da cui
nasce poi il musicista e li si mette a
fare scale arpeggi con trattati di
violino si si impara al solfeggio si
impara a leggere la musica proprio
ecco questi sono due differenti metodi
che però in realtà si completano
perché uno che ama l'altro e viceversa
qualunque sia il metodo qualunque sia
l'approccio la cosa importante è che non
smetterò mai di sottolineare
l'importanza dello studio degli anni di
studio
ecco come vedete dal grafico è stato
dimostrato scientificamente come se ci
fosse bisogno di dimostrarlo
scientificamente che più studi e meno
sbagli ecco allora è esattamente come un
attore come ma come anche uno che compie
studi normali sui libri più studi più ai
percentuali di riuscita
la scienza è entrata nel momento in cui
è riuscito a dimostrare che il cervello
di un musicista compie un percorso
talmente
dettagliato di unione tra quello che è
la percezione uditiva e la percezione
tattile di movimento la consapevolezza
corporea che all'aumentare degli anni di
pratica che sempre stato dimostrato che
più o meno è necessario sono necessari
56 anni di pratica intensiva
dicevo questo collegamento tra i due
sensi si sviluppa talmente tanto che un
musicista un violinista in questo caso è
in grado di riconoscere una differenza
di frequenza anche minima subito basta
che lui chiuda gli occhi e si ascolti i
suoni e riesce a percepire qualsiasi
cosa quindi per me che cosa è suonare il
violino
a livello tecnico io mi sono immaginato
sempre questa cosa che suonare il
violino è esattamente come entrare in
una stanza tutta buia completamente buio
immaginatevi una stanza totalmente buia
e il di regista deve conoscere ciascun
elemento della stanza tutto talmente
bene che riesce a muoversi senza far
cadere niente spostare le cose se
immaginiamo che fosse una cucina
potremmo anche essere in grado di cucina
di farsi un caffè senza vedere dove la
moka dove il caffè tutto bisogna saper
fare tutto in automatico e la fase di
studio quindi cos'è
io accendo una lampadina e vado a vedere
tutti i dettagli di questa stanza gli
studios gli studios per anni fino a
quando me li ricordo tutti e riesco ad
aprire gli sportelli riesco a muovermi
senza far cadere niente riesco a pulire
il servizio di cristallo senza causare
nessun danno per fortuna ecco è questo
muovermi al buio mi dà una cosa mi dà il
coraggio
ora il coraggio è fondamentale perché il
coraggio ci aiuta a eliminare le nostre
paure
quando noi suoniamo eseguiamo una
performance e la performance è data da
questa equazione
la performance è semplicemente il
risultato della differenza tra il nostro
potenziale e le interferenze che
intercorrono nel momento adesso
focalizziamoci un attimino sul
potenziale il potenziale di ognuno di
noi è un insieme
di infiniti fattori è la propria natura
il proprio percorso di studi il proprio
agio fisico nel suonare anche ci sono
persone che hanno molto talento perché
perché prendono in mano allo strumento e
sembra che non avviene mano niente
loro sembrano nati così oppure anche
un'espressione di potenziale è la
musicalità magari ci sono persone che
hanno una personalità tale per cui
riescono a tirar fuori un messaggio
musicale senza dover troppo studiare
invece le interferenze le interferenze
sulle interferenze si apre un altro
mondo se qualcuno di voi ha giocato a
tennis
probabilmente si ricorderà che
nell'istante in cui lancia la palla con
la tira palla con la racchetta
c'è tutto quel lasso di tempo tra quando
la palla vai quando la palla torna per
cui se entrano in gioco le interferenze
nella nostra testa e ci chiediamo dove
la butzer o la palla poi dove mila tir
era il mio avversario
cosa devo fare sarà sempre troppo tardi
per tirarlo indietro quando ci ritornerà
e questo porterà errore tirare la palla
fuori
tirar la rete ecco la stessa identica
cosa succede nella musica se noi mentre
suoniamo lasciamo spazio tutte queste
interferenze le interferenze vanno a
coprire tutto il nostro potenziale e di
conseguenza la nostra performance sarà
non di buon livello e noi torneremo a
casa e nel nostro io ci diremo che
potevamo fare meglio perché perché le
interferenze erano troppo grandi
allora ciascuno di noi deve imparare a
conoscere le sue paure le paure tipiche
dei violinisti sono e sembra banale
perché è una cosa da bambini paura di
far cadere lo strumento questo c'è anche
per i più anche per i più grandi e anche
per i più adulti
a volte sono arrivati da me allievi di
25 30 anni molto bravi che però
sbagliano dei passaggi perché perché
hanno paura di far cadere lo strumento
anche a me ammetto con umiltà a volte è
capitato magari di non sentirmi
totalmente a mio agio perché magari c'è
troppa umidità allora entrano in gioco
le interferenze e quindi li se gli lasci
spazio e non andrà bene dei visti
uscire a cacciarle subito in un certo
senso di riuscire a farti le amiche per
poi lasciarla in disparte
ecco questo credo che valga per
praticamente tutte le discipline
in realtà ciascun musicista studia sui
libri oppure suona tanto per abituarsi
oppure addirittura a volte si butta e
non ci pensa e lì va bene però ognuno di
noi deve imparare a conoscere le proprie
paure affrontarle e trasformarle in
energia positiva proprio per raggiungere
la formula del potenziale la formula
della performance
allora abbiamo parlato del coraggio il
coraggio porta ad altre due declinazioni
l'innovazione e l'espressività allora
nella musica l'innovazione come diceva
giuseppe verdi a giuseppe verdi chiesero
come ci si sente a essere un grande
innovatore della musica giuseppe verdi
ha scritto tra le migliori opere di
tutta la storia musicale e giuseppe
verdi rispose che in realtà lui non era
un grande innovatore ma era
semplicemente un artista che rimescolava
le carte e le ripresentava in maniera
diversa pescando addirittura tradizioni
di secoli fa quindi vivaldi bach quindi
quello che noi perseguiamo come grande
innovazione in realtà è il
rimescolamento di quello che c'è già e
ci sono nella storia della musica ci
sono diversi rimescolamenti eccellenti
basti pensare a bach con le sue fughe
che ha innovato dal punto di vista
formale la musica con la sapienza oppure
vivaldi che ha è riuscito nel seicento
settecento a riprodurre i suoni della
natura con i violini che se ci pensiamo
in un'era di adesso dove la tecnologia
domina e molto particolare che uno
semplicemente con un pezzo di legno con
un violino riesca a riprodurre il suono
della barriera dei cani o il cinguettio
degli uccellini o addirittura i ruscelli
e oppure beethoven che ha osato ha
inserito un coro all'interno della sua
nona sinfonia con l'inno alla gioia e
poi arriviamo oltre all'innovazione
abbiamo anche la componente
dell'espressività l'espressività e la
capacità comunicativa
fondamentalmente è anche questa può
essere studiata però come dicevo prima
c'è anche un discorso di attitudine
naturale
riguardante alla capacità espressiva
l'espressività e la capacità di
comunicare un messaggio pensate a un
attore che pronuncia una frase senza
accenti senza cadenze senza pause senza
niente nessuno pagherebbe un biglietto
per andare a sentire un attore piatto
che non dice niente allora
l'espressività inserisce la varietà
l'umanità all'interno della musica
voglio farvi sentire adesso un estratto
dal cantabile di paganini che è un
grande e stato un grandissimo musicista
un grandissimo di sinistra genovese del
xix secolo e primavela faccio sentire
brevemente senza espressività
dopodiché la prova a suonare con
espressività per farvi sentire la
differenza
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ecco avete sentito che queste sono
semplici note una dietro all'altra dici
bene sise intonato 66 si sai suonare il
violino però non c'è niente in quello
che suoni adesso proviamo aggiungere un
po di vibrato è un pochino del
cosiddetto fraseggio musicale
[Musica]
[Applauso]
avete sentito grazie
avete sentito l'enorme differenza che
c'è tra una frase non espressiva e una
frase espressiva allora torniamo
all'inizio di questo di questo talk il
tema dell'evento e l'andata e il ritorno
all'ora ea volte preparando questo talk
io mi sono detto ma l'andata è questa il
ritorno a questo oppure l'andate questo
ritorno a quest'altro no però potrebbe
anche essere questo è questo l'andata e
ritorno per un musicista non sono mai
definitivi perché si inseguono si
allontanano se vedete si allontanano si
avvicinano oppure si avvicinano si
allontanano diventano più forte più
piano
esattamente se pensate a una sinfonia mi
viene in mente adesso la quinta di
beethoven che quasi tutti conoscono è un
concentrato di contrasti uno dietro
l'altro che si completano
è come se litigassero facessero pace
sempre ogni volta vanno e tornano quindi
l'andata e ritorno non sono mai
definitivi qual è allora il messaggio
il mio messaggio quando suono il mio
messaggio e riportare un suono che
racchiuda dentro storia cultura popoli
sensibilità
in una parola umanità nel salutarvi vi
vorrei dedicare questo pezzo che è una
canzone riarrangiata da yashar heifetz
che fu forse il più grande violinista di
tutti i tempi
e lui ha preso questa canzone che è una
canzone folk a proposito del folklore di
prima di cui parlavamo prima
e la rieditata suonando con la sua
capacità tecnica che deriva dal metodo
russo quindi anche in questo caso i
metodi si incontrano e si completano
nella speranza di fare del bene
[Musica]
[Applauso]